[Musik]
zusammenhalt und solidarität zeigen ist
das motto des g 7 gipfel cinema zudem
heute morgen auf ukrainisch präsident
vilimsky zugeschaltet war
bundeskanzler scholz verurteilt bei
einer pressekonferenz am abend russlands
krieg und als g7 sind wir uns einig in
der einschätzung dass es deshalb sich
hier um sehr lang anhaltende
veränderungen dreht die die
internationalen beziehungen auch für
sehr sehr lange zeit prägen würden
deshalb ist auch klar im verhältnis zu
russland kann es kein zurück geben
guten abend willkommen zu einem zdf
spezial zum g 7 gipfel in emma die
staats und regierungschefs haben heute
weitere sanktionen gegen russland
beschlossen zielinski bat um schnelle
schlagkräftige hilfe um den krieg bei zu
beenden auch mit den fünf partner
staaten argentinien südafrika senegal
indien und indonesien ist man ins
gespräch gekommen über themen und
ergebnisse am tag 2 matthias kubitz
mächtige unter sich so gut wie jedes
bild bedacht während sich die männer als
coole kumpels und verantwortungsvolle
weltenretter inszenieren präsentieren
sich auf der ellmauer alm ihre frau
rollen und bilder scheinbar aus einer
anderen zeit
angesichts einer welt die sich auf
vielen ebenen gerade neu sortiert fünf
potenzielle partner haben sich die g7
heute eingeladen um sie zu gewinnen für
westliche interessen
spitzenvertreter aus indien indonesien
südafrika senegal und argentinien sind
dem ruf des deutschen gastgebers gefolgt
auf der agenda die ernährung global
sichern angesichts der getreide krise
und mehr zusammenarbeit beim klimaschutz
der kanzler will die allianz der
demokratien für diese globalen
herausforderungen vergrößern als
demokratien blicken wir ähnlich auf die
welt und es ist gut wichtig und nötig
dass wir uns miteinander austauschen
gegenseitiges zuhören schafft
gegenseitiges verständnis und das
erleichtert die zusammenarbeit
schwierig bis aussichtslos wohl aber der
g7 versuch die eingeladenen staaten von
den sanktionen gegen russland zu
überzeugen vor allem indien ist
wichtiger handelspartner russlands mit
engen beziehungen
ein paar stunden zuvor etwa 1500
kilometer entfernt wartet der
ukrainische präsident wladimir selensky
auf seine video schalte nach ellmau die
kameras müssen raus kurz bevor das
vertrauliche gespräch beginnt doch rasch
sicher durch selensky fordert von den g7
massive militärische hilfe für ein
kriegsende noch in diesem jahr die
g7-staaten rücken zusammen und haben der
ukraine weitreichende und langfristige
sicherheitsgarantien auch nach dem krieg
gegen russland zugesagt so lange wie
nötig
ziemlich genau 2000 kilometer von ellmau
entfernt in moskau wird der dereinst g7
zu g8 machte und wegen der krim annexion
wieder ausgeschlossen wurde genau
beobachten wie sich die welt nun
formiert um russland die stirn zu bieten
und
in garmisch partenkirchen also am
gipfelort begrüße ich seiner packungen
die sich bestens auskennt mit russische
außenpolitik verpackung der ukrainische
präsident war heute zum gipfel
zugeschaltet ist seine vorstellung denn
realistisch russland komplett wieder
raus bringen zu können aus seinem land
das ist sicherlich insbesondere bis ende
des jahres nicht realistisch gerade wenn
ihr auch schon an die langjährige
besetzung der krim oder auch des
brunnenwassers denken es geht kurz und
mittelfristig erst einmal darum die
russische offensive auszuhalten und dann
möglicherweise auch moderate
gebietsgewinne zu machen ob das aber
überhaupt möglich sein wird hängt vor
allen dingen auch von der qualität und
von der quantität der westlichen
waffenlieferungen habe und in den
letzten tagen an russland nach längerer
pause auch wieder kiew mit raketen
angegriffen ist das als zeichen gipfel
zu verstehen putin zählt auf die ganze
ukraine nicht mehr auf den dom was im
osten
das ist sicherlich ein deutliches
zeichen an die staaten hier auf 107 dass
trotz der maßnahmen die getroffen wird
russland nicht aufgeben wird dass es
eben eine langfristige stabilisierung
und westbindung oder eine langfristige
stabilisierung und westbindung der
ukraine verhindern will ist es natürlich
aber auch teil der kriegsführung gegen
die bevölkerung gegen die ukraine selber
um den widerstand mittel und langfristig
zu brechen
niemand kann sich einen langen krieg
wünschen aus humanitären gründen aber
auch aus wirtschaftlichen sehen sie dann
ein szenario in dem sich putin einlassen
würde auf ernsthafte
waffenstillstandsverhandlungen
also sie müssen davon ausgehen dass
russland sich darauf erst einlassen wird
wenn es davon ausgeht dass es
militärisch seine ziele nicht mehr
erreichen kann das ist im übrigen auch
ein fazit oder eine eine
übertragungsleistung die wir auf anderen
konflikten machen können das heißt eben
auch dass die ukraine russland
militärisch an den verhandlungstisch
zwingen muss und da sind irgendwie
gesagt noch mal die westlichen waffen
die von umso wichtiger und ganz zentral
für dieses ziel
was meinen sie sondern mit putin reden
etwa auf dem g20-gipfel im november oder
ist das sinnlos und stärkt den unnötig
also ich glaube die frage ob man mit ihm
redet ist gar nicht die kritische
sondern eher was man ihm sagt wenn wir
uns anschauen wie die gespräche mit
putin beispielsweise von bundeskanzler
scholz oder vom französischen
präsidenten makro verlaufen sind dann
ist es doch häufig so dass das in
russland wahrgenommen wird als eine art
von kriegsmüdigkeit dass man
möglicherweise nicht bereit ist
langfristig die ukraine zu unterstützen
und darauf zählt man natürlich in moskau
das heißt man kann durchaus mit ihm
reden man muss aber in ganz klare
botschaften zur unterstützung der
ukraine an den senden vielen dank zara
packung nach garmisch partenkirchen
und dann schalten wir auch nach moskau
zu unserem korrespondenten axel sturm
axel wenn man die staats und
regierungschefs hier so hört hat man den
eindruck putin sei total isoliert wie
sieht man das im kreml
ja ganz und gar nicht so im gegenteil
man sieht das genaue gegenteil also dass
sich die welt verändert so wie wir es
eben im beitrag gesehen haben das ist
dem kreml hier auch sehr klar dass es
auch staatspräsident putin klar und
deswegen sucht man hier natürlich nach
neuen ver bunden bündelten und versucht
sich neu auszurichten man hat er schon
sehr erfolgreich gemacht mit dem export
von
energieprodukten da geht jetzt vieles
vergünstigt nach indien und china
und man guckt auch wie es geostrategisch
und militärisch aussieht also von
isolation in der selbstwahrnehmung kann
hier in moskau keine rede sein ja es
werden immer neue sanktionspaket gegen
russland geschnürt auch auf diesem
gipfel waren die bisherigen den wirksam
das liegt im auge des betrachters die
wirtschaftssanktionen kommen schon an
man ist sich ab jetzt schon sehr darüber
im klaren dass die
supermarktregale zwar noch gefüllt sind
dass die produkte auch die westlichen
produkte hier noch ausreichend verfügbar
sind aber es ist natürlich klar dass die
lieferketten unterbrochen sind und dass
es keinen nachschub geben wird deswegen
stellt sich die russische wirtschaft
unter anweisung des russischen
präsidenten darauf ein dinge selber
produzieren zu müssen so was ähnliches
gab es in der russischen geschichte
schon mal kurz nach ende des zweiten
weltkrieges heute gab es die meldung
dass russland möglicherweise technisch
insolvent sein könnte weil es
zahlungsverpflichtungen im westen nicht
nachkommen konnte das sei aber sagt der
kreml nur einen sozusagen vom westen
kreierte insolvenz die man nicht ernst
nehmen dürfe also der langen rede kurzer
sinn ja die sanktionen kommen an aber
sie kommen langsam an vielen dank für
die einschätzung nach moskau
ja der gipfel hat viele themen das
format g7 aber auch viele gegner zu
wenige bestimmen darüber zu viele sagen
die kritiker und ein thema wieder
globale klimawandel steht seit jahren
auf der agenda ohne dass sich
grundlegendes ändert ein buntes bündnis
aus gipfelgegnern hat protestiert erst
in münchen dann in garmisch wer sind sie
was fordern sie und warum sind es
deutlich weniger als erwartet
cornelia donath berichtet
zugegeben das muss man wollen eine
wander demo 20 kilometer hin und zurück
hoch in die berge nicht mal 100 trauen
sich das zu insgesamt sind es diesmal
deutlich weniger als bei früheren
gipfeln
erklärungsversuche man zeigt die ganze
zeit mit den kameras mit den mikros auf
den rosa elefanten auf der kulisse das
sind dann zuerst die pandemie dann jetzt
so kleine krieg aber beispielsweise die
demonstranten vom freitag user dann hat
man im grunde weitestgehend die resonanz
gestohlen es ist anstrengend schwül und
heiß warum tun die gipfelgegner sich das
an der kapitalismus hat ausgedient dass
es kein system er das tragbar ist also
es gibt das ist ein system das auf
unendliche wachstum beruht und es gibt
kein unendliches wachstum auf einem
endlichen planeten kann ja mal anliegen
wichtiges millionen für mehr
klimagerechtigkeit zu protestieren und
die hielt nicht adressieren will die
sitzen nun mal auf der anderen seite des
berges aber es gibt eine kleine
auserwählte gruppe von 50 aktivisten die
mit drei bussen sehr viel presse und
noch mehr polizei zumindest in die nähe
des schlosses geschüttelt wird und
würdig heißt es immer wieder halte ich
dieses polizeiaufgebot für vollkommen
übertrieben das ist ja ein
betreuungsschlüssel den würde ich mir
ich arbeite mal wünschen oben angekommen
geht näher als 500 meter ans schloss
nicht dran für die demonstranten eine
farce
ich bin nicht zufrieden ich fordere mehr
recht wir müssen wenn sie entscheiden
dem planeten zugrunde zu richten haben
wir auch das recht daneben zu stehen und
laden ein zu sein ich wir sind keine
terroristen wir sind menschen mit dem
anliegen und gerade die menschen die
jetzt gerade reden die haben eine
wirklich wichtiges anliegen bei denen
geht es um die existenz
dann folgen rangeleien und sechs
vorläufige festnahmen weil rettungswege
blockiert worden sein
währenddessen schwitzt und schnauft die
wander demo sie will das klassische g7
themen wie hunger und klimakrise endlich
wieder mehr aufmerksamkeit erregen und
mehr aktives mobilisieren der krieg in
der ukraine dürfe nicht alles andere in
den schatten stellen
in berlin begrüße ich jetzt den grünen
chef omid nouripour genannt
kein wunder die sorge vieler
demonstranten aber sicher auch viele
grünen-anhänger ist dass das thema
klimawandel fast untergeht sehen sie
diese gefahr auf dem g7-gipfel
es sind 600 milliarden vereinbart worden
und jetzt in infrastrukturprojekte
fließen sollen des so genannten globalen
südens also da starten die noch große
entwicklungspotenziale haben und wenn
dieses geld ausgegeben wird ohne dabei
auch klimaschutz zu achten dann ist es
einfach weg und und da werden neue
fakten geschaffen die uns nicht helfen
und deshalb ist es notwendig dass gerade
bei diesen beschlüssen gefasst worden
sind die an sich richtig und notwendig
sind ganz genau darauf geachtet wird
dass sie zum welt abkommen zum
klimaschutz vom pariser passen wir sind
ja mitten in einer gipfelwoche erst eu
jetzt g7 der nato ein zeichen der
geschlossenheit soll da gesendet werden
reicht das
das zeichen von geschlossenheit ist in
ellmau gesetz das ist auch gut so aber
es wird natürlich nicht reichen am ende
wird das relevant sein dass wir
zusammenstehen in diesen schwierigen
zeiten also demokratie und zwar auf der
seite der menschen der ukraine an der
seite der menschen in not rheine aber
auch im kampf um unsere freiheiten und
demokratie um weniger geht es gerade
nicht in der ukraine
ukraine us-präsident elends kehrt heute
um schnelle massive unterstützung
gebeten mit dem ziel den krieg noch vor
dem winter zu beenden wie realistisch
ist das
dass die leute in der ukraine und dass
ihr präsident
immer klarer lauter und verzweifelter um
schnelle hilfe und waffenlieferungen
bitten ist verständlich wenn man sich
die lage im don was anschaut dann sieht
man die dramatik sieht man die
notwendigkeit des schnellen handelns das
ist auch allen bewusst sowohl den
parteien in der bundesregierung als auch
unseren partnerstaaten und deshalb wird
mit hochdruck gearbeitet damit diese
schneller hilfe auch kommen kann das
zuweilen den ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
nicht schnell genug ist ist noch einmal
verständlich aber wir werden tun müssen
was möglich ist und was notwendig ist
und das in balance der vermeidung ein
herr entgrenzung dieses krieges denn
niemand hat etwas davon wenn die nato
und russland naser nase einander
gegenüberstehen vielen dank für das
gespräch und mit nordbank gehen
das gespräch haben wir vor der sendung
aufgezeichnet tag 2 in ellmau und einer
woche der gipfel die eu gesehen nato
entschlossen und geeintes zeigen ob es
gelingt die fünf sogenannten
partnerstaaten mit ins boot zu holen
gerade was die verurteilung des
russischen angriffs auf die ukraine
betrifft ist offen
das war unser zdf spezial hier geht es
jetzt gleich weiter mit einem wiso
spezial zur energiekrise darin handfeste
tipps wie sie energie und geld sparen
können auf wiedersehen
[Musik]